thank you who go and thank you I'm it
then who go for giving me this
opportunity actually uh be asked me to
underline this so that you don't confuse
me with with Abby but i guess this long
name shouldn't be hard to distinguish
well actually the ID card they printed
had it this way so I thought let me you
know when someone comes and sees me they
should realize that I am the same person
just kidding sounds good I used the joke
the next time alright so I mean I've
been working too long in sort of general
secure computation not caring about
efficiency but off late a lot of people
have made a lot of progress in
constructing efficient protocols for
secure computation and this is sort of a
joint board with me and Abby sort of
entering for me at least into this area
of thinking not just rethinking about
efficient secure computation all right
so clicker is working all right so
what's the general framework for secure
computation well there is a first step
where you compile the functionality into
one of several things boolean circuits
or thematic circuits Oh RAM and then
there is a step to where you use a
generic approach for one of these
primitives and there's been a long line
of work that has done it and more
recently there have been more efficient
approaches to construct secure
computation but here I want to sort of
say that for certain specific problems
specific approaches could yield more
efficient solutions for instance private
set intersection has been extensively
studied and now we know very efficient
protocols to securely compute set
intersection so what am I going to talk
about today is a new sort of algorithmic
approach to design secure computation
protocols and I'm going to begin with a
beautiful work by agarwal Mishra and
Pincus that shows how to construct a
secure computation protocol for the
median for computing securely computing
the median
and i should say this is highly
efficient and actually extremely simple
to explain so the idea here is that
Alice and Bob have a set of inputs at
each so the protocol goes in iterations
in each iteration Alice and Bob locally
compute their median so let's say si is
Alice the set of inputs and SB is Bob
set of inputs they individually compute
the median and then they securely
compare their medians ok the check if ma
is less than mb and depending on what
the result of this secure computation is
they pruyn their data now intuitively
speaking if Alice's median among her
local set of points is less than Bob set
Bob's median then the final medium
median will not result in the top half
if ordered analysis input or the bottom
half of Bob's input so those data
elements are pruned here and then it's
recursively you recursively go on into
what survives ok so roughly this is the
idea to securely compute the media yes
so how do you so okay you'll give this
protocol is this better than generic
schemes or not when is it better how so
the thing that you need to look in this
protocol is sort of the communication
complexity so the communication
complexity you should look at how many
what is the number of rounds in this
protocol if n is my data the number of
data elements then the number of
iterations is login because at each
iteration you you prune out half so the
number of launches log in and the
computation that's done in each round is
a secure computation of comparison of
two elements so if you think that L is
the length of these the it's order L if
you're just worrying about semi honest
security to compute the secure
comparison of these two data elements so
this is more efficient the generic
circuit approaches which would
definitely depend on the input size that
would still require going through every
element or at least the runtime and the
runtime for computing the median is
still the same is linear okay so that's
a good question and that comes to my
next light so let me walk through how
this how this works and let me answer
than Bernie's question too so Alice and
Bob have the set of inputs at each
iteration they locally compute their
median they compare and depending on the
output they're going to prune so if ma n
is greater than mb then Alice prunes the
the bottom half and Bob prunes the top
half and this goes iteratively until the
they survive with just one element and
then they can compute and find out what
the median is so now is this actually
secure what is being securely computed
is just the comparison but is this
secure so I'm going to show the security
in the semi honest case and I'm going to
talk about the malicious a little later
so consider simulating Alice what is the
simulator have the Alice the simulator
has the set of inputs and it also has
the median now what does it mean that
the simulator needs to simulate this
this V
so it essentially boils down to finding
out what the result of the comparison is
going to be in each iteration if it
knows the result of the comparison you
can show that you can individually
simulate each of these interactions ok
so the beautiful part here is if I know
what the final median is going to be if
I just set the Bob's value to be this
median and just repeat this computation
I would precisely get the same outputs
for each of these secure comparisons so
in some sense it does not leak any
information at all you can recreate the
entire transcript just with the input
and the median and again this is the
semi on this case we will talk about the
malicious a little later okay so this
work is the the work of Agarwal mishra
and Pincus they show that using just
secure comparison they can compute the
median what more can you come can you
compute just by using the millionaire's
problem and what we show is that a host
of problems can actually be solved just
by using secure comparison from convex
hull minimum spanning tree some job
scheduling problems single source or
destination shortest paths and some
approximations and if you notice
actually there is a unifying factor here
they are sort of related to metroid and
submodular optimization with a small
caveat that i will describe later yes
Michael yes and
same breast hobbies and think they can
to program analysis and automated find
the median we can example you give if
you give it a program and the program
analysis food has infrared us this
intermediate without our okay with this
and they will synthesize after the car
you mean automatically check if it
doesn't reveal that you're saying that
the program can automatically know that
a simulation exists I mean I'm not aware
of this word but that would be my
question but when you say program
analysis do you mean the concept of
information flow where this is slightly
different okay I'm not aware of this but
we can discuss after okay so these are
our results yes but how is the day the
distributed so basically the set of
points is known to both of us but the
edge lengths the the edges and the
distances we share disjoint set of edges
and we have the the edge lengths are
something that I know this is only for
two party for now it is possible to
extend it to a multi-party but I'm going
to talk with me about to party today a
little bit yes and actually I'm going to
talk about quite a bit yes yes in all
these cases that saw the the input is
distributed across the two parties okay
so what do we achieve in a sense if I
want to summarize this table in one line
is that we sort of achieve close to what
would be the insecure communication
complexity for each of these cases would
be or in in other words actually if you
see what the communication complexity
that we achieve using our framework is
in all these cases proportional actually
to the output length so for instance
take the convex hull if 0 is the output
size the number of elements in the
convex hull our communication complexity
is actually proportional to that and I
mean this is just a comparison with the
circuit
om and roughly if you see the aether
depend on the input size or they have
some poly log factors that they depend
on the communication complexity yes
actually outputting the convex hull I
know that I'm ignoring some of the
security parameter but yes it is
actually outputting the convex hull yes
I'm outputting the minimum spanning tree
the minimum there's minimum spanning
tree size is exactly equal to n minus 1
by the number of vertices so that's why
it's v times L ok so I just wanted to
say there is some related work in
achieving sort of this minimum value for
the convex hull using some data
oblivious algorithms the work of Epstein
goodricke and tamashii are they show how
to do it and some part of this some
flavor of the same result that we have
for the case of minimum spanning tree
and single source was already appeared
in brickell an article alright so what
is the underlying idea that sort of
captures all these algorithms and as my
title suggests it's going to be the
greedy algorithms so all of these
algorithms can be solved by some greedy
algorithm so what is our framework we
are going to say suppose there is a
function that can be computed that fits
this framework then we can securely
compute it so what is this framework so
first we are going to require that there
is a unique solution between our set of
points this assumption can be removed
using tricks that was already presented
in agarwal atolls work but I'm going to
have this requirement that we have a
unique solution then the second property
is that there is a unique order in which
this output is going to be presented in
the greedy algorithm so in the greedy
algorithm you you iteratively output the
answer and I I will require that there
is the order in which these elements are
going to be output is unique by the
greedy algorithm so if you think of the
local greedy heuristic as this function
f
SF applied on the entire set of data
points gives the first element and then
iteratively given the previous outputs
if I apply this local heuristic I get
the next greedy output and finally I'm
going to require this local update
ability property and this is sort of
very specific for the two-party
computation where we require that this
local greedy heuristic can actually be
done by using by first locally computing
the answers on these two decomposed
parts U and V of the set of data points
and then combining them using a less
than function or a comparison of the key
value associated with these two things
now the best thing to think when I'm
looking at this greedy framework is the
minimum spanning tree problem so if you
all remember the greedy algorithm it is
to increasingly it is to order the edge
in increasing order of weights and then
at every step you add the next edge that
does not form a cycle now the local
update is to find the next edge that
does not form a cycle and that can be
locally computed and then the edge
weights can be compared even if the sets
are decomposed okay so to just show how
we can if a function satisfies our three
notions the computation the secure
computation is going to roughly follow
this protocol Alice and Bob at each
stage are going to locally compute the
next greedy step they're going to find
the element think of this as the edge
you a and VB and the keys are basically
the edge weights they're going to
compare which edge is smaller and
depending on what the answer is they're
going to the output of that iteration is
actually going to be that edge now this
is a slight distinction from the secure
medium problem where the outputs were
just yes or no there was no part of the
output that was revealed but here you
actually reveal the output of the
computation partially in each step so
this is this is it so using this weekend
any function that is secure greedy
compatible according to the three
properties we can achieve secure
computation using
protocol so first let me just quickly
argue correctness correctness follows
because I said there is going to be a
unique solution and my there is a unique
order in which this is computed and it
can be decomposed to two parties so just
by the three properties the correctness
directly follows of this protocol
because at each step i compute the next
greedy output correctly now how do i
achieve simulation now if you recall in
the median problem I said to simulate I
just need to know the answer of every
intermediate comparison or of every
iteration I need to know what is the
output ahead of time then i can just
simulate it but the point is here that
the simulator gets the input and the
output now given the input and the
output the simulator knows what is the
unique order in which it outputs so it
can simulate the entire interaction just
with the input and output because I have
this unique order property of my
algorithms this is clear so far okay so
this shows that we can simulate it in
the semi honest case now I just want to
sort of tell here that what primitives
in general so I said all these
primitives can be done here but in
literature we already have a primitive
that abstracts all greedy algorithms and
those are Metroid's now what r Metroid's
i'm just going to be very quick here a
very high level Metroid's is basically a
set system which contains a finite set s
and a family of subsets which satisfies
two properties one is the hairy
deterring property which says that if
any set is a part of the family then any
subset of it is also part of the family
and the second one which is the more
crucial part of Metroid's is the
exchange property which basically says
that if i have two elements two sets in
the family one bigger than the other
then i can pick one element in the
bigger set add it to the smaller set and
it will still be in the family okay this
I is typically referred to as the set of
independent sets now a weighted Metroid
as in
case of weighted minimum spanning tree
and job scheduling is that each of these
elements of the set are also associated
with some weight and a theorem of Oxley
from 92 I just found this reference
actually it said that the greedy
algorithm finds the maximal independent
set with minimum cost there is a greedy
algorithm that given a baited metroid
can output the independent set with
maximal weight or even minimum weight
depending on what you want so what is
this greedy algorithm the greedy
algorithm for a set system with a weight
function is first you start you're going
to grow your output so you set your
output to be empty then you first
consider the elements of the set in
increasing order of weights this is I
mean the way to think of this is through
the minimum spanning tree so you
arranged the elements in increasing
order or decreasing order depending on
you want to find the minimum or maximum
and then you iteratively find the next
element in the sequence such that a
union X is still independent in the case
of minimum spanning tree you want to
find the next edge that does not form a
cycle or the next edge that grows the
forest ok so and finally you return a so
this is the greedy algorithm for the
Metroid's in general the weighted
Metroid problem now for us to adopt the
Metroid's to our framework we need it to
be secure greedy compatible and we can
ensure this if it has unique solution
and unique order as I mentioned and
local update ability and in the case of
Metroid's if the weights are all
distinct then this property is satisfied
and the local update ability can be
guaranteed if we can check membership in
this metroid set system locally ok in
the case of minimum spanning tree this
is possible because we can check if it
forms a cycle or not and we can do this
locally
even if the weights up there is a unique
solution it is in the case of matrix a
if it's you there is a unique solution
okay so the question is okay so far I've
only talked about the semi honest honest
but curious sitting what about the
malicious security and of course we want
to do this while preserving the
complexity now interestingly for the
median case this is in fact possible so
let's just quickly look at the the
median example again we said that we
could simulate this in the semi honest
setting by just using the input and
output but when you move to the
malicious case you actually have to
extract when you're simulating an
adversary you need to extract the
adversaries input it's not given to you
you need to extract it now it was
already shown in the in agarwal at all
paper how to extract these inputs so
this is sort of the the tree of all
possible computations that can occur
when you are simulating or when this
interaction proceeds so if you look at
it let's say that Alice and Bob have
eight elements each now at the beginning
they compare the medians of their set so
it will be the middle element so a four
and b four there are two outcomes yes
and no and then if it's yes they prune
whatever their respective halves and
then they consider the next median to
compare now if you look at it you can
actually given the adversary the
adversary reveals the median or reveals
his input if it is the output of the
median at the leaf till then there is no
input that has been revealed now what
you can do is the simulator can sort of
run this interaction with the with the
adversary think of this in the
comparison heibel where the simulator
can set what the output of the
comparison can be it can actually
explore this entire tree and literally
find out every input of the adversary
and this idea was already demonstrated
in the in the previous work however it
didn't handle a small case where for
instance if an adversity aborts in the
middle of a computation
what do you do so the idea first you
could extract all the inputs but what if
the adversary aborts here what does this
mean it means that you cannot you cannot
hope to extract a 3 and a 4 because the
adversary might abort at this node and
a-three and a-four revealed only at the
bottom leaf so in some sense this this
subtree is completely hidden but what we
show is that even in this case we can
actually simulate even when the cave and
the adversary is aborting and the idea
is actually a simple idea what we do is
that we actually repeat this value over
the inputs that are missing because of
the abort and now this might be
surprising is this actually the correct
input to feed to the ideal functionality
to get the answer and i'm just going to
on a high level tell you why it is ok
it's because the median the final median
depends on the honest part is input
that's going to be revealed by the ideal
functionality and there are two cases
either the median is going to be outside
this hidden area but it's going to say
that the median is actually here now I
argue that if the median is outside
there it is already handled as before
but if the median is handled here the
simulator all it has to do is it already
explored this path it can output that
view where it aborts right there and I
mean these values have so carefully be
chosen that this simulation will work so
actually the secure median protocol can
also be extended to the fully malicious
case now how about the other examples
that we presented in our work we don't
know in general for the general case if
we can in our framework achieve
malicious security and I'm going to say
that well we can simulate it if sort of
the properties that held that was held
for the median also applies to our case
we will be able to do it and informally
speaking the two properties are that
there are only polynomially many these
computational paths or partial
transcripts as i showed in the tree it
was a polynomial size tree and
everything could be
so you need polynomially many sort of
partial transcripts and you also need
another interesting property that at
every intermediate interation the input
use fed into the secure comparison has
to be sort of unique up to this partial
transcript and I'm going to roughly tell
you why this property is required the
point is that if there were two paths
that led to accessing the same input now
the adversary could adaptively decide to
abort in one of these two cases and such
a case cannot be simulated because the
adversary is aborting depending on the
honest party's input and you can never
hope to achieve sort of simulation in
that setting that being said I'm not
saying that it is impossible I just we
just don't know at this point if we can
extend this idea to the malicious case
unless these two properties are sort of
satisfied but the good news is that we
try to achieve the next best thing which
is covert security how much time do I
have oh okay so I'm going to sort of
quickly say this on a high level what is
covert security covert security requires
that if the adversary cheats he should
be caught if he doesn't abort in the
execution so it's sort of just capturing
the case when the adversary does not
abort you can think of it in a
simplified manner that way okay so how
do we what do what does it take to
achieve covert security first let's just
see the two problems that arise when a
couple of the problems that arise in
extending our framework to the covert
setting one is that the adversary could
adaptively select inputs based on what
has been partially revealed think of the
convex hull if some set of points have
come the next point could be adaptively
decided by the adversary we can fix that
by making the adversary commit and use
those inputs so that way we can avoid
that problem the second thing is it
might fail to follow the the greedy
update procedure what it could consider
it inputs out of order meaning that it
could skip a few it could skip a few
elements when it is in successive
iterations based on the partial outputs
so these are sort of broadly the two
main issues in achieving covert security
and our idea is to use signatures and
consistency checks to to ensure that the
adversary does both these things and I'm
just going to give you the ideas
involved in this so we're going to have
an input commitment phase where the
adversary where both the parties commit
to the other inputs we can use
extractable input so that the simulator
can extract the inputs during the
simulation and in addition Alice and Bob
are going to share some verification a
verification key to the other party then
in the secure computation face it's
going to be exactly as before in our
original framework and in addition the
outputs are going to be signed by both
the parties and finally there's going to
be a consistent check face yes but for
the covert case it's not okay yes ok so
the consistency check face is about
showing that every input was correctly
used now the inputs can be used in two
different ways one it is part of the
output and input is part of the output
for instance in the convex hull one of
the points is in the power in the convex
hull and the other is if an input is not
the each party needs to show that an
input is either part of the convex is on
the convex cells that's been output or
it's not part of the convex hull and if
we want to hope to get ok we don't get
output complexity but we if you want to
get close to input complexity
commitments won't cost too much but we
sort of want to show that the
consistency check for every input can be
done in 01 sort of there is a no one
witness that shows both in and out of
the input and I'll just argue this for
the convex hull but there are some
interesting ideas that we do for the
metroids and the minimum spanning tree
as well but I just want to quickly tell
you for the convex hull there's a simple
idea to show why there is an order one
witness so what do we want to show we
want to show for every input commitment
prove that either the value that point
is part of the convex hull that's being
output
or we need to show that it's not part of
the convex hull that's not part of the
optimal solution now the first part is
easy because they are going to get
signatures on the output that is being
the on the final output so they can just
show that they have a signature for
things that are already part of the
output but for things not part of the
output I need a short witness to
demonstrate that it's not part of the
convict sir and the idea is simple we
know that if there is a point inside the
convex cell and we need to show that
this cannot be part of the convex hull
we just need to pick three points in the
convex hull and show that this point
lies within the triangle of this so
that's a short witness for demonstrating
at this point that was part of my input
was not involved in the computation
because it's not part of the convex hull
so in this way we can get the
consistency check and I'm going to skip
the cases for the Metroid's and the
minimum spanning tree and I'm just going
to quickly go to the results
all right okay so we can show actually
for the convex hull the job scheduling
and the single source destination paths
our computation is actually we have the
regular secure computation that depends
on the output size and we have the
consistency checks that's just
proportional to the input size well I
mean I've not compared it with the
others but the others definitely depend
on the input as well as they have some
poly log factors now regarding
communication efficient malicious
security we can rely on genetic
techniques like universal arguments or
snorts and we can actually achieve we
can port our algorithm we can get it
communication efficient we can get it
proportional to the output complexity
but however this is going to cause some
issues it's going to increase the
computational cost very high if you're
thinking about efficiency now a good
open problem that you've all had
suggested when I presented this at a
previous venue was that a concrete open
problem that we can state here is can we
get communication optimal malicious
secure computation in the OT hybrid and
why I'm saying is the IOT hybrid is are
not going to have any other assumptions
which means I actually don't know how to
construct universal arguments and snarks
in the OT hybrid we don't know yet so
this is a good open problem to think
about can we get communication efficient
malicious secure computation even for
the problems that we have mentioned here
and I'm just going to conclude so
essentially the the general theme of of
our work here is to sort of port the
paradigms that we know in algorithms to
get secure computation we want to
leverage the techniques such as greedy
algorithms to get efficient secure
computation and in our case we used only
the comparison operation another open
problem is what about other primitives
do we have some interesting primitives
for graph algorithms and with that I
just want to say that a good future goal
is can we get general techniques as
opposed to four circuits Turing machines
and rams can we get it for algorithmic
paradigms let's say like dynamic
scheduling or divide and conquer thank
you